c'est un homme aux qualités
extraordinaires à l'amitié à la finalité
est effective une gentillesse j'ai
appris chez jean-claude parce que il a
un coeur gros comme ça
c'est un enfant mineur c'est un homme
d'éthique politique de moralité et de
progrès je club et comme il est là des
élus martiniquais les plus atteints y
existe et vous pouvez en être fier
lourdes amendes
c'est un peu la règle du genre lors des
présentations de liste le concert
d'éloges et de rigueur face à quelques
300 sympathisants ce soir jean claude et
qu'en ville est évidemment l'homme de la
situation
après quelques atermoiements il est
candidat à sa propre succession pour un
troisième mandat consécutif
entouré de ses 25 colistiers la belge a
bein n'a que 19 ans et participer
activement à la vie galerie en
maintenant 10 des exactions et puis
vient l'heure du bilan
naturellement jugée confortable des
précédentes mandatures
il faut dire que le carbet se distingue
par une vision singulière de l'industrie
du loisir et de la culture vision qui
retient toute l'attention de l'urbaniste
serge letchimy a gardé son authenticité
tout en menant une politique
d'attractivité
et tout le monde connaît route pour
busan aller au restaurant des cabots
galets ou la plage bagarre b et c est là
il a réussi à allier les deux sa
réussite est ce assez exceptionnel parce
qu'il a su combiner à la fois
l'attractivité le patrimoine
l'authenticité et le bien-être de la
population
mais que serait une campagne électorale
sans quelques égratignures aux
adversaires politiques notamment lorsque
l'on évoque le cas de l'ex hôtel marouba
liquidée depuis 2015 maintenant est
toujours en quête de repreneurs
je crois que le promoteur inas donc
menti c'est appris ici la machine à
céder ici l'an prochain et fera tomber
j'ai envie de se montrer
j'avais ce que monsieur boucher lui a
dit lors d'une réunion si bref dhabi
soit aussi la collectivité tabassé mon
soutien aux bleus avec sa peau
si la pratique de ce métier
qu'à cela ne tienne jean claude decamps
vide entend bien réaliser nombre de
projets comme un village d'activités ou
encore développer les beach sports il
espère pour cela être victorieux dès le
premier tour une performance raté de peu
en 2014